oui d'accord c'est pas les plus
agréables à porter mais c'est la plus
emblématique c'est pour ça je te montre
juste à quoi ça ressemble et puis si
c'est peu la plus agréable à porter
ouais voilà je garde tout cas je garde
pas un signe de l'équipe
oui non non oyez oyez gentes dames et
gentilhomme de bourgogne franche comté
saviez vous qu'il était possible de
faire un voyage dans le temps
we dance et là c'est possible cette
semaine je vous emmène au moyen âge
c'est une période qui a duré dix siècles
et qui continue aujourd'hui d'avoir le
vent en poupe dans notre région quoi
ne croyez pas d'épreuve ce sont par
exemple des bâtisseurs de toutes sortes
et puis d'autres associations font des
combats de chevaliers il y en a d'autres
encore qui reproduisent les dents du
xiiie siècle
ne cherchez plus c'est l'art
[Musique]
c'est
c'est mon périple débuté au château de
malves à une trentaine de km de dijon
c'est là que nicolas et ses compères
m'attendais de grands enfants qui à leur
âge joue est encore aux chevaliers
[Musique]
k qui font kiffer nord
celui-là
qui
je
[Musique]
arrivant
oui mais non
les agences qui vendent du talent
[Musique]
aulas
l'association décroisée de l'idiot
l'anneau rejoue des scènes de la vie du
moyen-âge et là j'arrive est en pleine
bataille
[Musique]
imaginez donc nous sommes au 12ème
siècle au moment des croisades les duels
faisait partie de la vie quotidienne
[Musique]
nicolas un ancien journaliste joue le
rôle du seigneur du château de mâlain et
avec lui or il vaut mieux ne pas trop
jouer au malin
pourquoi ces cons m c'est mon neveu il a
provoqué des ingénieries notre notre
invitée hier soir au banquet
il avait bu un peu trop d'hypocras et il
a prétendu qu'ils pouvaient battre
dimanche
or là il se prend une pâte et monumental
à la démarre donc le vainqueur aura
l'honneur sauf ça
exactement c'est pour ça qu'ils
combattent exactement bahia
tu peux pour être sûr que c'est toi tu
peux plus respirer là je vais souffler
est ce que tu veux de l'eau ouais il
fait une chaleur ça vous voyez pas mais
et puis ça et ça s'appelle sacrément
lourd et puis en plus et toulouse
combien de tas de poils assure-toi
complet 14 kg ça commence à faire
c'est toi qui fabrique ses doigts sur
betway
je fabrique toutes les horreurs mais
t'as peut passer l'âge ou au chevalier
toi non non bien sûr que non il n'y a
pas d'âge pour faire ça y'a pas d'âge ça
fait quand même temps que tu joues ça
fait dix ans dix ans mais t'as quel âge
28 et tu as appris à manier les armes de
combat en les regardant
alors on a des manuscrits donc ici dont
un peu plus tardif qui sont 15e et 16e
siècles mais on voit des techniques de
dp et des maniements des positions pour
le combat donc on n'interprète par
rapport à ça en plein dans le mille
des cons et écuyers on apprend à tirer
alors qu'un très important même si on
s'en sort plus pour chasser oui que pour
la peau de bête que tu utilises est là
pour vise exactement c'est assez mal vu
par les meubles de tir à l'arc parce que
ces normes de lâches
on s'est concerté cette accalmie elle
était alors pas vraiment c'est mes
gardes qui tire de l'audio détour
éventuellement certainement culture
alors qu il ya des concours des fois on
reprogramme s'exercer quoi je suis prêt
je viens donc la télé mettre ton pouce
tu fermes le point faire la main il en
fait tu vas légèrement inclinée marque
pour que la flèche propose alors
attention non on a très peur en fait il
est en train de partir de quitter son
plan de travail doit figurer en mesure
de bâtir et qui quand je tiens aussi à
tirer sur la corde
encore encore encore encore
encore à aller lâche c'est pas mal
[Musique]
nicolas m'invitait à rester pour le
déjeuner au menu poulet à la ficelle et
tartines de chennai c'est un fromage
d'origine anglaise qui existait déjà une
13e 7 et pendant ce temps là l'autre
nicolas combattants prenez son pain
j'étais surprise de voir que
contrairement à ce que je pensais les
gens se lavait au moyen-âge mais tout le
monde dans le même bain et le seigneur
en premier bien sûr nous avec fanny on
en profitait pour se faire belle et
parler des dernières robes à la mouche
bon ben vous avez dû le remarquer j'ai
changé d'avis ça ce n'est pas mon habit
traditionnel non c'est le sous vêtement
traditionnel médiévale c'est fanny qui
me l'a prêté parce qu'elle a quelques
projets pour moi fanny si tu m'as donné
ce sous-vêtement j'imagine que c'est pas
pourquoi je reste comme ça mais non tu
vas pas restons sous vêtements ça se
fait pas c'est beaucoup qu'est ce que tu
as prévu alors
alors voilà ta robe donc ça c'est ma
robe d'hiver elle a un petit peu lourde
bon ben alors là on est couvert
jusqu'aux pieds est-ce que ça c'est une
particularité de l'habit du moyen-âge
pour la femme
alors tout à fait donc les statues ses
bas on peut voir le bout des pieds mais
à partir du moment où on est noble le
costume est ample et très long donc on
ne doit pas voir le bout de tes pieds et
à l'arrière tu as une petite reine comme
moi tu vois
parce que si tu te baisse il faut
absolument pas voilà exactement il faut
pas qu'on voit les filles à l'arrière
voilà donc ses amples et c'est long la
couleur que je porte la cette couleur
elle a une signification j'ai choisi une
couleur assez saturé donc une couleur
qui est peut-être moins vive que la
mienne mais qui aurait quand même forte
et bien saturés puisque les nobles comme
ils ont l'argent peuvent faire plusieurs
bain de teinture ce que ne peuvent pas
faire les pauvres qui teinte avec des
choses qui tiennent mans longtemps dans
le temps qu'ils sont plus fade
donc en effet c'est une couleur plutôt
pour une personne noble
donc toi tu est noble toi tu as beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
oui moi je l'espère flash il
la thèse eu leur place et quelle était
la tendance j'imagine qu'il ya des modes
et des tendances bien sûr aussi à cette
époque alors il ya des modes qui sont
très reconnaissables
après c'est pas comme aujourd'hui on a
une collection printemps été et automne
hiver la mode elle a plutôt tendance à
varier en fait sur sur 25 ans on va dire
ah oui
qui
[Musique]
ça fait nicolas doyon qui tout est ce
plus honorable et a regardé avec écoute
pour aller aux banques et ça me paraît
tout à fait je vois c'est patrick voyer
chevaux mes oreilles à fait d'accord
mais c'est vrai mais non non bonjour
très chers messieurs et dames et
damoiseaux et damoiselles puisque je
n'ai pas trouvé d'hypocras sur la route
j'arrive les mains vides je suis désolé
puisque mêmes m'asseoir ici qu'est ce
que vous mangez dans ce bon banquier
tout d'abord daniel d'hommes gaël
honorifique
c'est pas super à côté du monseigneur
oui
les fameux feu ce que les bourguignons
mais circuit de bresse sur notre table à
nous nous avons du poulet qui a été
forcée abricots deux amants vous avez dû
chaude a donc là ce qui est sûr cette
table ce sont des plats typiques des
recettes typiques médiévale donc
l'intérêt que vous devez être lavé les
mains en fait engueuler la cuillère et
enfin me disais c'est trop ça on mange
avec la trinité
les trois doigts à trinité vous prenez
avec les doigts vous mettez dans votre
assiette
d'après ne pouvait pas des petites
boulettes avec dans le plat c'est pour
ça qu'on a tous mes mains propres vous
mettez dans votre assiette
explique moi ce qu'on peut trouver leur
de manquer au moyen âge ça c'est du
poulet avec des abricots une farce aux
abricots
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres du personnel
d asi voilà il ya du des épices dedans
donc il ya du pauvre long de dent donc
une épice assez caractéristique du moyen
âge je me régalais aussi de la salade de
fenouil poireau du riz safrané et de la
tarte ou pire
mais j'avais plus de mal avec l'eau
chaude une sorte de saucisse pas
vraiment léger comme plat alors qu'il
veut de la saucisse et on avait des
serviettes au moyen âge parce que là
j'en ai franchement c'était l'anah
plutôt festif et joyeux
mais vous êtes une association et puis
vous êtes là pour vous amuser aussi
d'ailleurs tu disais tout à l'heure
c'est ma famille ma famille la famille
médiévale c'est incroyable quoi on a une
famille pour le week-end parce que les
sorties qu'on fait là où l'intérieur
mais ça peut être les sorties en
extérieur sous tente un des campements
où vous vous emportez la nourriture les
couchages les peaux de bêtes tout sur
place il fait tout au feu de bois
on dort sur place dans des lits avec
dépôt tout ce qu'ils avaient à l'époque
on essayait de retrouver l'ambiance de
l'époque
voilà c'est pas une démarche
archéologiques c'est pour revivre ce
qu'ils ont vécu avec je vais outils
qu'on connaissait de l'époque côte il ya
plein de l'association la vôtre elle
fait la part belle à l'histoire une
recherchiste es et ce que tu me disais
il ya plus une recherche d'historicité
on pourra jamais être à 100% comme à
l'époque parce qu'on ne disait pas je
suis désolé mais ma vie en fait ouais
c'est ça il ya une crise mais il s'est
mis à pleuvoir beaucoup à ça c'est
l'éclair ça tonne dehors la pluie s'est
mise à tomber donc ils sont tous partis
furieusement pour ranger leur épée leurs
armes de ce matin du compas qui sont
restés dehors et leurs mailles qui
veulent pas abîmer
donc voila mais je les attends je suis
au coin du feu de la bière et 700 civils
tôt le matin je prenais la route pour
l'ual je m'étais souvent demandé comment
les hommes du moyen âge
construisez les châteaux baptiste avait
promis de répondre à mes questions et
pour cela il m'avait donné rendez vous
en plein coeur de la forêt de ghetto
[Musique]
imaginez vous qu'il ya vingt ans il n'y
avait rien le château vous voyez a été
construit par des hommes ils sont
salariés ils sont 90 ils reconstruisent
tout l'équivalent de ce qui se passait
avant au moyen-âge les bâtiments de
façon traditionnelle
c'est à leur découverte que nous allons
évidemment et puis je lui rangé mon
téléphone portable parce que comme à
l'époque le réseau ya pas
[Musique]
encore
série bat us c'est au nom
qu'est-ce que tu en train de faire et on
est en train de construire en ce moment
une des grosses parties du château c'est
toute la façade sud et ça sera tout ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on appelle la porte
entre deux tours donc l'entrée
principale du château qui est défendu
par deux gros sous qui font 20 mètres de
haut donc comme la tour de la chapelle
aussi haute que celle là combien de
temps vous allez prendre pour faire avec
ce genre d'outils pour faire une tour au
cidre aussi importante que celle là
alors là on peut ce qu'il met à votre à
3-4 ans en termes de maçonnerie pour
vraiment finir le courage pour élaborer
un tel pour faire un tel chantier ce qui
serait pas plus facile d'utiliser des
grues moderne et bien sûr c'est sûr ça
serait beaucoup plus facile on serait
beaucoup plus productif
oui mais le plaisir pourquoi retrouve un
contact avec la matière on retrouve
finalement une humilité un respect
puisque on est dépendant par rapport à
notre niveau c'est que tous les
matériaux là on va les trouver sur place
localement la pierre elle vient de la
carrière du site
les arbres viennent de la forêt le sable
pareil du sol du socle rocheux et donc
forcément tout ça ça permet de se relier
entre guillemets à son environnement
comme un oiseau en fait finalement qu'il
construirait santé has et ça c'est très
joli
tu peux me montrer un geste mais celui
que tu que tu fais pour construire
beaucoup d'atouts ben là on a vraiment
donc là on utilise un têtu on appelle ça
donc ça c'est vraiment l'outil du maçon
de pierre donc c'est un outil qui est
conclave outils là aussi du moyen âge
qu'en est il donc la partie sa
particularité c'est ça regardez qu'est
ce que ça permet ça et ben du coup on a
des arêtes et on va se servir de cet art
est en fait pour envoyer une ligne de
fracture dans la pierre
je veux briser cette pierre je vais
frapper un peu de côté comme ça et c'est
ma dernière question en arrivant j'ai
passé je me suis un petit peu courbé
pour passer sous deux grandes roues
qu'est ce que c'est que ces objets c'est
la grue médiévale 1 c'est ce qu'on
appelle un gruat tombeau une cage à
écureuil aussi c'est un engin de levage
ni plus ni moins et donc avec ça on peut
facilement monter à deux personnes 500
kg aux kiwis donc c'est très bon donc
c'est quand même oui très performante je
peux faire un tour dans cette petite
cage à hamster bien tu peux sortir de là
[Musique]
j'ai dans le
des premiers tours qui sont pénibles ça
envie de vomir sa venue après le petit
des lesbiennes
[Musique]
ici j'ai facilement pu observer le
travail des ouvriers et poser toutes les
questions que je voulais cette proximité
avec les bâtisseurs du château explique
le succès de guiglo
écoutez bien trois cent mille visiteurs
par an en quelques années c'est devenu
le deuxième site le plus visité de
bourgogne après les auspices de pau
les
[Musique]
le chantier existe depuis 20 ans et les
travaux dureront encore 20 ans de
nouveaux projets sont lancés et j'ai pu
visiter un village du moyen âge avec un
potager uniquement constitué de plantes
de l'époque et en végétal qui a de la
famille de la carotte
donc c'est le carvi c'est une plante en
fait qu'on a redécouverte
quand on a fait nos recherches justement
sur ce qui poussait à l'époque donc
était déjà présente à l'époque de
charlemagne est en fait l'idée c'est
donc ces graines là c'est aussi bien
voilà des aromatiques on va pouvoir
utiliser en cuisine
voilà c'est poule là elles sont
particulièrement malines le coq ya ici
les il a survécu à un hiver tout seul là
dans les bois sans avoir besoin d'être
enfermés au cra donc donc du coup on
essaye de d'être plus malin en fait que
les animaux qui ici à l'origine du
projet de guédelon il ya florian c'est
le maître d'oeuvre de chantier son
objectif est non seulement de bâtir un
château mais aussi de transmettre le
goût de l'histoire aux jeunes
générations les ouvriers du chantier ils
ont deux métiers
ils construisent et le travail est réel
chaque jour qui passe c'est les murs qui
monte et dans le même temps ils sont
aussi
médiateur du patrimoine espère qu'ils
vont transmettre
ils vont expliquer ce qu'ils font et
c'est vraiment ce que gay l'on a inventé
en termes de profil et de type de
travail donc ça c'est pas évident tu es
passionné et en parle avec une verve à
bainghen lancé aussi un groupe une
aventure humaine qui fait qu' on a
finalement réuni ici on est en 20 ans
quasiment que des passionnés de façon
quelqu'un qui est pas passionner ici bon
oeil au pot on vient pas travailler ici
on va dire comme on vient travailler
ailleurs c'est vraiment la chance de
réaliser une passion et aussi d'en vivre
vous aimez oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est physique de gueule on est là ça va
toujours de 3,6
[Applaudissements]
voilà ce qu'il faut que les plus
officielles bien
[Applaudissements]
là
haguenau on a autant de femmes que de
garçons à genkai même os à peine un peu
plus de femmes qui traversent que la
parité c'est important bonjour à deux
réveils
[Applaudissements]
il me restait à apprendre l'art très
important au moyen âge celui de latence
et pour ça j'avais rendez vous avec
evelyne as un vérin j'ai rendez vous
avec une association ce sont les vilains
de saint bérain et il m'avait donné
rendez vous ici alors je connaissais pas
forcément lieu mais c'était pas
compliqué de savoir où il est et l'autre
lorsque je suis passé en voiture
j'entendais la musique et ça faisait pas
de doute que c'était bien la musique
médiévale
donc je vais monter d'un semis rodez
pour s'empêtre et puis vous allez me
suivre
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous
quelle jolie musique on entend depuis la
route dès l'arrivée est ce qu'on en sait
beaucoup au moyen âge mais c'était un
moment de réjouissance beaucoup chez les
villageois et là on aimait se retrouver
pour un tas de fête et danser des carole
détresse que des brol donc ça ce sont
les noms et danse carole 13 ans dans ses
bras puis avait aussi toutes les danses
des seigneurs les danses de court et
dense qui sont plus majestueuse avec des
seniors comme je vous disais dansé par
exemple des pavane d'où vient le mot se
pavaner donc c'était très codifié il
fallait vraiment avoir une attitude
majestueux port altier or la tête et se
montrer c'était l'occasion de montrer
aussi ses vêtements son niveau dans la
gare archives dans les seigneurs et vous
alors vous êtes les paysans les
villageois ou vous êtes la noblesse de
l'époque mais plutôt comme notre cité du
12è 13è siècle on est plutôt du xiiie
siècle et on est plutôt des villageois
puisque le nom de notre association se
les est le vilain riner est vilain ce
sont des paysans des paysans libre qui
ont des terres mais qui paient leurs
redevances aux seniors alors ça donne
quoi cette danse on essaye alors je
regarde et après j'intègre alors vous
faites signe quand vous pensez que j'ai
assez regardé bonbons lance la musique
maestro
[Musique]
après cette ronde où les hommes et des
femmes dans son ensemble c'est le
tourdion celle dont se faisait oublier
la dureté de la vie au moyen-âge et puis
elle avait aussi d'autres intérêts par
exemple celui d'aplanir le sol pour la
construction d'une maison
mais surtout ces moments est l occasion
pour les jeunes gens de se rencontrer et
pourquoi pas de se séduire
ce n'est pas la seule à passer un mois
[Rires]
[Musique]
mêlant sais pas si je fais comme s'ils
avaient une robe un parcours fléché
[Musique]
alors j'ai une question pourquoi
certains portent des bouquets de fleurs
d'autres pain en fait c'est d'être
d'accord général on danse le soir avec
des torches sur toute façon au moyen-âge
pas mal de dents c'était fait pour
flirter pour flirter à quand fdr de ses
je voulais montrer je souffle au lycée
la merci beaucoup à lire merci a dit
donc gg pas compris comment faire le
tour enfin vous avez rien vous allez
m'expliquer non plus merci merci
l'honneur est sauf nous fin et
l'appareil honnête elle sait danser
cette chanson à wimbly elle y arrive
classiquement c'était d'usagé au moyen
âge oui on connaît les marionnettes
depuis un moment parce que l'église en
fait pour pouvoir illustrer les
histoires que l'on raconte est un les
histoires religieuses comme c'est en
latin personne n'y comprenait rien alors
on a commencé à créer des petits sujets
en bois pour animer les histoires et
c'est comme ça que marie est devenu
petit mari marionnet marionnettes mari
puis marion mari
comme elle l a le bras extensible elle
peut étendre son prénom comme ça à
l'infini alain et donc ont fabriqué des
petits sujets en voit et on a commencé à
les allumer petit à petit a déjoué sur
les foires et ça c'est vulgariser ben on
apprend plein de choses un dans celle en
plein de plein de choses
[Musique]
et bien c'est une période qui finalement
n'est pas si sombre que ce qu'on a dit
voilà pas comme la robe que je porte
aujourd'hui voilà c'est là c'est terminé
pour aujourd'hui
je vous remercie encore de tout mon
coeur de votre fidélité
restons connectés sur le blog les
réseaux sociaux je n'embrasse très très
fort et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine by bonne semaine
[Musique]